The Hunger Games The Ballad of songbirds
and snakes is on its way this November
and while it will feature a brand new
star-studded cast it's reminding all of
us of the OG movie The Hunger Games has
become a classic but no matter how well
you know the film itself that doesn't
mean we know what went on behind the
scenes and what it was really like on
set warning things got pretty wild get
ready for an amazing and sometimes
hilarious new look at this fan favorite
film if you consider yourself team Peta
then you'll probably be happy to see
just how well Jennifer Lawrence and Josh
Hutcherson actually got along on set
there's plenty of behind the scenes
footage that shows how close these best
Pals were during filming as well as just
how much fun they made things on set for
fans of the film it's hard to imagine
much goofing off going on in between
takes since the scenes themselves were
so tense and serious yet these two
managed to make the downtime fun I know
what you're gonna say peeing in the
ocean
together yep yep they preferred to
always stick together on set because we
never like to be separated and then when
we go to the bathroom semantics we have
to separate there were plenty of onset
pranks on the very first movie we had um
I took a fake dead body and I put it in
her bathroom but in many ways their
off-screen friendship made their
on-screen relationship even better I
think it's using kissing a stranger yeah
I mean like at least you like the person
of course not everyone is a Peta fan if
you're more team Gale then there's
plenty of adorable behind the scenes
moments for Jayla and Liam Hemsworth who
plays Gail as well of course it's clear
that these two knew how to get down to
business just as much as they knew how
to Goof Off seeing 10 scenes being
recorded shows just how well these two
were able to switch into work mode if
you couldn't already tell the Hunger
Games had some serious shenanigans on
set in spite of its solemn subject
matter I think it's the funnest set I've
ever been on I've never done this much
cutting up and laughing let's focus too
much on the laughter but it seems that
the cast and crew's goofy Nature Made
for a supportive work environment now
fight scenes are an important part of
The Hunger Games so this silly little
cast had to get serious when preparing
for their on-screen combat the actors
had a gym where they could train for
their fight scenes and some of the
actors enjoyed training so much that
they'd get in extra training time
whenever they could spare it on set now
training for fight scenes wasn't just
fun it was important for preventing
onset accidents and injuries
unfortunately it couldn't prevent every
onset injury which is why Jennifer
Lawrence actually went deaf in one ear
while filming in one scene a jet
punctured her eardrum and left her death
in one ear for months while this
certainly made things more difficult for
the actor it did add a bit of irony to
the film since in the book series that
the film is based on Katniss also goes
deaf in one ear for plenty of movies
hair and makeup and costumes play a
major role in making the end product
what it is when it comes to the Hunger
Games these characters Aesthetics aren't
the first thing that comes to mind in
reality though hair makeup and costumes
helped to make these characters
iconic why else would Katniss side braid
have become super popular among young
girls at the time well you might be
surprised that this wasn't just thanks
to a simple hairstyle it was actually
thanks to wigs thirty thousand dollars
worth of wigs in the first two movies
Jennifer Lawrence dyed her blonde hair
brown but for the second two she wore
five wigs that totaled thirty thousand
dollars as for the other characters hair
no one was allowed to have the same
braid as Katniss as a result over 100
different types of braids were used
among the cast and while we may not have
known all that went into these braids to
look at them there's one character whose
hair makeup and costume was clearly
Quite a feat now that would be you
guessed it Effie Trinket who's played by
Elizabeth Banks and while her look is
Iconic and adds a lot to the film Banks
felt that her rather extreme look made
it difficult for her to goof around
between takes like the others you know
I'm stuck in this in this all day long
sort of depressing actually while the
cast kept the set feeling Lively
award-winning director Gary Ross kept
things in order and behind the scenes
footage shows him in action I want
everybody to feel like you're scared
imagine where you're coming from and
imagine this could be you and everything
will fall into place okay it's easy to
see that while he may have been hard at
work he enjoyed being a part of this
film just like everyone else so who was
your favorite character from The Hunger
Games to see behind the scenes who do
you think had the most fun on set let us
know in the comments and for more videos
like this one like And subscribe to the
things